في منطقة البحر الكاريبي الجنوبية على بعد 50 ميلاً فقط
من ساحل فنزويلا ، تقع
جزيرة بونير الهولندية
تحت سطح الشعاب المرجانية ذات المياه الفيروزية التي
تتشبث بالساحل
وهي موطن لأكثر من 350 نوعًا من الأسماك ،
لكن دراسة حديثة استمرت أربع سنوات هنا
انتهت في  أظهر عام 2020 تبيض مرجاني سنوي
يصل إلى 61 ،
وهي ظاهرة تكشف عن علامات
الإجهاد التي
قد تكون قاتلة للكائنات الحية ،
ومن الآثار الكبيرة لتغير
المناخ بالطبع ارتفاع درجة حرارة المحيطات
كما رأينا في بونير على مدار
العامين الماضيين  هناك الكثير من التبييض
الذي يحدث ولكن لحسن الحظ ليس الكثير من
الشعاب المرجانية التي ماتت ولكن بالطبع إذا
استمرينا في مواجهة أحداث التبييض المكثفة الكبيرة هذه ولم تحصل الشعاب المرجانية
على الوقت الكافي للتعافي ، فقد
يغير ذلك شكل الشعاب المرجانية
في عام 1979  تم منح المياه حول الجزيرة
حماية خاصة كأحد
المحميات البحرية الأولى على كوكب الأرض
منذ ذلك الحين حظر الصيد في
المحمية بالإضافة إلى حظر
رسو  d تتم مراقبة أي إزالة للشعاب المرجانية
وتنظيمها بواسطة مؤسسة stanapo
park ،
اليوم ، تحتفظ الشعاب المرجانية بمكانتها
كواحدة من أكثر المناطق الصحية في منطقة البحر الكاريبي
اليوم ، ونحن نقوم بفحص بعض
مستشعرات الضوء ودرجة الحرارة التي وضعناها
في المنتزه ، لذلك باستخدام هذه المستشعرات ،  يمكن
الحصول على فكرة عن كيفية تغير درجة الحرارة
على مر السنين هل هذا
التغير في درجة الحرارة هو نفسه في
جميع المنتزهات البحرية ، هل هو نفسه في جميع
الأعماق وهذا يمكن أن يساعدنا حقًا في
المستقبل إذا كنا نخطط للقيام
بالاستعادة من خلال  استهداف الأنواع المرجانية التي
تعيش على أفضل وجه وفي
أي نطاقات درجات الحرارة التي من شأنها أن تعمل بشكل
أفضل من أجل الاستعادة وكلما فهمنا بشكل أفضل
أنه كلما كان بإمكاننا
حماية وحفظ ما لدينا
على مدار السنوات العشر الماضية ، فإن
تجديد الشعاب المرجانية بالمنظمة المحلية يستخدم هذه
المعلومات القيمة من أجل  تنفيذ
عملية استعادة الشعاب المرجانية الطبيعية
تسمى
التفتت ، نقوم بنشر الآلاف
والآلاف من الشعاب المرجانية في مشتلنا
ونقطعها فقط  مثل نوع من البستنة
تحت الماء ، فلنفترض أن لديك
المرجان ونحن نسميها المستعمرة الأم ، يمكنك
قطع جزء منها وهذه القطعة
قادرة على شفاء الندبة أولاً ثم
البدء في النمو ، لذا فإن الشعاب المرجانية الجديدة
ستكون نسخة من  المستعمرة الأم
بهذه الطريقة تقطع ،
نحن قادرون على إنتاج نبات قديم يعود
إلى الشعاب المرجانية ما يقرب من عشرة آلاف من الشعاب المرجانية
سنويًا
، وتركز معظم عمليات الاستعادة على
نوعين من المرجان المتفرعة والقرن
المهددة بالانقراض وكلاهما
مهم كمأوى
عندما بدأ المشروع ، أخذنا عينات من جميع
أنحاء الجزيرة
تقريبًا 50 سلالة مختلفة من هذين
النوعين ، نحتاج إلى العثور على الشعاب المرجانية
الأكثر مقاومة ، فهي أكثر مرونة
لرؤية التكاثر بالطبع الذي
نمت منذ أن كانت شظايا صغيرة
لقد أمضيت بضع سنوات تعرفها
أولاً في الحضانة ثم في
زراعتها ومراقبتها على
مر السنين ورؤيتها تتكاثر ، إنه
أمر مجزٍ جدًا لي  الإجابة أن
ما تفعله هو حقًا إحداث
فرق ،
فأنا متفائل جدًا بشأن
مستقبل الشعاب المرجانية في بونير ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
تحديد الشكل الذي نريد أن يبدو عليه المستقبل
ومن ثم نحتاج إلى اتخاذ الخطوات
للتأكد من أننا نستطيع  حماية هذا
المستقبل ،
أعتقد أننا وصلنا إلى النقطة التي يمكننا فيها
اتخاذ تلك القرارات التي من شأنها التأكد من
أنه في غضون 20 عامًا ، ربما تكون بونير واحدة من
الأماكن الوحيدة التي يمكن أن تبقى في حالة جيدة ،
ولا يزال لدينا شعاب مرجانية جميلة جدًا ،
وهذا كوكب يستحق  تخبرنا الحماية
كيف ترد على المكالمة
باستخدام هاشتاج cool to earth
[الموسيقى]